kellyanne there's not a single thing i
can look at that i would say joe biden
is doing successfully i never thought
things would get this bad this fast uh
is there anything that you see that he'd
be willing to do
that could be helpful
in terms of ukraine energy the economy
inflation
sean they have to be looking at the same
polls we all see which has him down all
around town as you say america feels joe
biden and kamala harris literally do
nothing well right now there's no issue
where they have a net approval rating on
that issue so if i were they i would do
a course correction i would have taken
the time at the democratic retreat in
philadelphia to do breakout sessions
reince and i have been at those
republican retreats that's what you do
you have one on energy one in the
economy one in education one on health
care and you come up with solutions that
your party can live with and you go out
and you buck up the american people sean
i've never seen a president
so unwilling to do that course
correction number one but number two
so unwilling to channel the pride the
spirit the resilience the moxie of
america as the american president it's
the ukrainian president that's been
inspiring so many people the way he's
trying to protect and safeguard his
country and our president is making us
less secure making everyday life less
affordable in and is worrying people on
everything from education to abortion to
inflation to immigration now they can
course correct i think you're going to
see all these new phony polls saying oh
his approval rating is going up the
democrats are
they're tightening the generic ballot
look at that
he didn't even benefit from unifying a
country because of an international
crisis
usually a president can a president can
rely upon five six seven more points
just when there is crisis and
uncertainty elsewhere where we feel
there's an american interest he hasn't
even benefited that way and you see why
he's yelling at america again from
philadelphia he's blaming putin blaming
the rest of us don't forget 40 of the
gas hike happened before putin ever even
invaded ukraine don't forget a couple of
months ago joe biden was blaming gas
prices and inflation on the supply chain
crisis on the quote pent-up demand for
post-pandemic travel you cannot have an
american president that has an america
last policy and blames american blames
americans in america for what's going
wrong he needs to step up and reflect
the best of who we are hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else